hi everyone is there honor to be here  too  and at first I want to thank you my  family my uncle who sent me here and  supports me far away from Taiwan at a  time and my and Tamas my boyfriend my  composure and cooperate a story with me  and be there for three years when I was  in u.s. long distance yeah and eating  John Johnny T who would make the sounds  for many of my films together at least  let us see my mentor Sheila's of BN and  and we'll say Brooker and Cathy  Christine and KZ is like a lot of  faculties in USD is the first supported  through this film and of this demotius  studios i intern in LA which is really  helpful for me to develop this film and  all my friends who is like far away from  taiwan the studio a guy kept in touch  with me in a social media yeah and of  course the act a female foreign is great  towards where you been for us and it  would be a big staff word movie forward  to the morn the independent film thank  you